all right the president just wraps up
another huge rally this time in West
Columbia South Carolina where he took on
critics he pushed his agenda and so much
more
let's take a look remember what I said
we're gonna start winning again we're
winning we're winning now like we have
it window like we have not won before
we're winning with our military our
military is now being built up like you
wouldn't believe we're winning with our
military we're winning on trade we're
winning on trade with defending our
borders because if you don't have
borders you don't have a country you
don't have a
oh it's happening that's how
[Applause]
well it's happening it's not build that
wall anymore it's continue building that
wall because of a building let's build
that wall and by the way we're almost a
year and a half into the Trump
presidency
many on the left this is now serious
they are totally completely utterly
psychotic and unhinged now remember this
wasn't supposed to happen
Donald Trump was never supposed to be
elected by you the people in fact when
he was inaugurated in January last year
remember many on the left
many Democrats melting down lashing out
with threats of violence directed at
President Trump and the White House
himself let's bring you down memory lane
yes I'm angry yes I am outraged yes I
have thought an awful lot about blowing
up the White House when was the last
time an actor assassinated the president
clarify I'm not an actor
now imagine just imagine for a second
this was said about Obama in the early
months of him becoming president and
let's not forget about Kathy Griffin's
bloody severed Trump head photoshoot
Robert De Niro fantasizing about
punching the president in the face and
telling him to f off every other day
here is why let me explain why this is
all happening the left not only they
never expected Donald Trump to win they
never thought he'd be this successful he
is a threat to everything wrong about
them his success is the left's worst
nightmare in other words they need
Donald Trump to fail if the Democrats
ever want to regain power well that
one's their power they're hoping for
they have to pray for failure that means
you fail that means America fails that
means the Forgotten men and women will
continue to be forgotten you know Bill
Maher probably the only honest one he's
hoping for a recession really doesn't
affect him now here we are one and a
half years into the presidency of Donald
Trump what do we see in 500 days the
economy is booming record unemployment
rates in 14 states we have more jobs
than people on unemployment we have
literally the lowest unemployment ever
recorded for african-americans Americans
Hispanic Americans women in the
workplace we have the highest GDP growth
in over a decade we have the lowest tax
cuts the biggest tax cut we've ever had
we've had a demolishing of burdens and
regulations we had successful
negotiations so far that are ongoing
with North Korea Isis is defeated and on
the run the Iranian stupid deal of Obama
is dead
Jerusalem promised by so many presidents
is now the capital of Israel and so much
more with each success the Democrats
dreams of kicking Trump out of office
becomes more faint and more remote and
now they feel it and they're lashing out
they don't like his success that's why
it's getting louder and more insane by
the day and the left is actually now
targeting those who actually work in
poor president Trump look at this New
Jersey so-called senator president
wannabe cory booker is calling for
americans to confront trump officials
look at maxine waters she's been calling
for Trump's impeachment since almost his
first day in office
well Maxine Waters is urging supporters
to accost Trump allies wherever they go
this is dangerous
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
those associated with president from
there now being targeted by America's
viciously angry left-wing all over the
country they're doing it to women and
children
now listen to what happened to Florida
Attorney General she'll join us in just
a few minutes Pam Bondi this weekend as
she goes to see the mr. Rogers movie
take a look three huge guys came up and
started probably an inch from my face
screaming at me every word in the book
cursing as loud as they could so then a
trooper my trooper came up and my
boyfriend and I got our tickets were
headed in and then they ran in and
circled me where I could not get into
the theater they stopped me so he came
up then and stopped them so then we went
in the theater thought it was defused
we're up getting popcorn at the
concession stand and they came up again
just every curse word in the book and
they're this far from my face one spit
on my head now I can't say that was
intentional because he was yelling so
loud I don't know if it was just him
spewing out of his mouth picking on
women and children now the Attorney
General will be here in a few moments
she'll give us more details on that and
she's only the latest Trump allied to be
targeted White House press secretary
Sarah Sanders
literally thrown out of a weekend this
weekend in a restaurant Lexington
Virginia named the red hand take a look
many of I now have heard that I was
asked to leave a restaurant this weekend
where I attempted to have dinner with my
family my husband and I politely left
and went home I was asked to leave
because I worked for president Trump we
are allowed to Grist disagree but we
should be able to do so freely and
without fear of harm and this goes for
all people regardless of politics some
have chosen to push hate and vandalism
against the restaurant that I was asked
to leave from a Hollywood actor publicly
encouraged people to kidnap my children
and this weekend a member of Congress
called for people to push back and make
clear to those serving their country in
this administration that they are not
welcome anywhere anytime for anything
healthy debate on ideas and political
philosophy is important but the calls
for harassment and push for any Trump
supporter to avoid the public is
unacceptable again threatening women and
children what is wrong with you people
on the left and according to Sanders
father former Arkansas governor Mike
Huckabee the harassment did not end
there listen to what he says once Sarah
and her family left and of course Sarah
was asked to please vacate Sarah and her
husband just went home they had sort of
had enough for the rest of her family
went across the street to a different
restaurant the owner of the red hen as
nobody's told this then followed them
across the street called people and
organized a protest yelling and
screaming at them from outside the other
restaurant and creating this scene now
following this incident the president
tweeted out quote the redhead and
restaurant should focus more on cleaning
its filthy canopies doors and windows
badly needs a paint job rather than
refusing to serve a fine person like
Sarah Huckabee Sanders I always had a
rule if a restaurant is dirty on the
outside it's dirty on the inside but
what is dirty here is a dirty political
discrimination from the red hen coming
just a few days after our DHS secretary
Kirsten Nielsen secretary Nielsen run
out of a ABC restaurant by a group of
other angry left-wing protests
this is getting out of control take a
look and it gets worse
on Friday morning more protesters around
it secretary Nielsen's home blasting
audio recordings of crying children and
as it turns out no one associated with
Donald Trump is now safe from what is
now a mob mentality of the left not even
children are safe as you just saw with
Sarah Huckabee last week we first
reported the president's 12 year old son
the target of a vile attack just like
secretary Nielsen on Twitter from Peter
Fonda
yeah Hanoi Jane's brother and she
tweeted in part quote we should rip
Baron Trump from his mother's arms put
him in a cage with pedophiles and see if
the mother will stand up against the
giant blob that she's married to now
president Trump's four-year-old
granddaughter was also threatened on
Twitter by a Canadian writer now both
these people okay they apologized for
these horrific threats
where are the arrests you know what
you're not allowed to threaten the first
family
what about Madonna you're thinking an
awful lot about blowing up the White
House Secret Service ever talked to her
where's the compassion of the left
I thought the democratic party had a
monopoly on love and peace and
compassion apparently not and of course
you wouldn't know the extent of this
vitriol if you only watch the mainstream
media check this out in fact according
to a report news Buster's your
establishment corrupt destroyed Trump
media in America totally ignored the
story about Trump's four-year-old
granddaughter
and while the left's anti Trump rage is
spinning out of control well some in the
media as sick as they are are actually
adding fuel to the fire they can't
control themselves they've all lost it
look the problem that Sarah Sanders had
over the weekend which is a absolutely
legitimate problem but who cares should
someone who lies constantly and enables
the president's lies be openly welcomed
in society wherever they please should
they face any kind of social or societal
pressure I'm increasingly weighing
towards yes is it okay that these people
can't go to restaurants and get heckled
I think that that's speaking truth to
power literally let's be honest to me
that's what America is about people in
power speaking them sharing your views
look you make choices in life you'll
make choices in life and there is a cost
to being an accomplice to this cruel
deceitful administration let's just take
a step back and remember all this hatred
coming from the left was initially
spurred over reports that children were
being forcibly separated from their
parents after attempting to cross the
us-mexico border illegally and it was
Donald Trump last week he never made
that law that was law was passed by
Congress signed into law by another
president but he did sign an executive
order halting any separation of families
until Congress can step up do their job
and change the law as they should have
done a long time ago but that doesn't
stop many of these crazies on the left
from demonizing Donald Trump many
cheered for example this Time magazine
cover you see that there's the big bad
horrible president and a little girl
who's crying because that little girl
according to Time magazine had been
separated from her mother and father
well the only problem is the girl was
never separated from her mother or
father ever the magazine cover I liked
so much in the news today is a lie and
time believe it or not it's standing by
their cover for sale now at a bookstore
near you
and then the media wonders why the
American people call them fake news why
they chance CNN sucks
you wonder why Americans don't trust you
now the truth is so many in the
left-wing media they're not fair they're
not balanced journalists as they claim
to be instead they're shills they're an
extension of the Democratic Party and
it's plain and simple and the agenda for
the demo
pratik party by the way if they get
elected it's pretty simple it's not a
shock here it doesn't matter whether the
Democrats running from California West
Virginia they're all working toward the
same thing what would they do we're
going to impeach Donald Trump but we're
not going to tell you please Maxine just
stop saying it we're gonna do it just
don't say it and then of course they
want to keep obamacare and open borders
oh and yeah they want you they want
their crumbs back remember you got the
biggest tax cut ever in American history
and Nancy Pelosi called the crumbs they
want the crumbs back so they can spend
your money now that's why what we're now
heading into and we're gonna have a lot
of coverage on this this is the most
important midterm election in modern
history and like every two to four years
the Democrats were now in the crazy
season and in the crazy season they used
same playbook and that is a campaign of
identity politics to convince you
Republicans are evil they claim
Republicans are racist and sexist and
misogynist and xenophobic and homophobic
and Islamophobic that Republicans want
dirty air and water that they want to
kill your children and by the way if you
have a grandmother they want to throw
her over the cliff now to demonstrate
this absolute fact well tonight's a
Hannity history lesson to bring you back
let's take a look back through time at
example after example of example of
Democrats using race and gender to
divide this country so that they can
convince you Republicans are all evil
just to win votes they'll say and do
anything for power take a look many
Republicans talking coded racial
language about takers and losers they
demonize President Obama and encourage
the ugliest impulses of the paranoid
fringe if you accept the support of Klan
sympathizers before you are president
you will accept their support after your
president he's gonna let the big banks
once again write their own rules unchain
Wall Street you're gonna put y'all back
in Chains it's wrong what the leader of
the Republican Party and this Congress
are doing in blocking an accurate census
because they don't want to count
everyone that they don't think they can
count on they are in favor of
affirmative action if you can dunk the
basketball or sink a 3-point shot but
they're not in favor of it if you merely
have the potential to be a leader in
your community and bring people together
don't tell me we've got a colorblind
society you let another church explode
when you don't vote
you allow another cross to burn
that's Paul Ryan throwing granny over
the cliff
flash forward back to today and you
think I make this up we clearly have a
whole new level of nastiness coming from
the left some are so obsessed with
hating and taking down this president
that they're clearly end up looking
insane which is pretty much all liberals
today look at actor Tom Arnold is
hell-bent on trying to say anything
negative but he's having a hard time
with words and answering simple
questions do you have any tapes of the
president that the public is not already
aware of yes you can't tell me you say
the content of the taste because you
want people watch your show yeah we're
having fun with these Trump tapes but
this is serious to be poppy and I'm not
effing around did Michael Cohen tell you
specifically really just yes or no that
he is cooperating with the authorities
should charges be brought
do not want to answer the question no
you don't want to answer the question
right okay because will you let us know
what you learn over the weekend since
you're spending the weekend with Michael
Cohen mm-hm
that's 30 seconds see you never ever had
they said nothing and tying Trump to a
litany of conspiracies that he has
nothing to do with is even harder which
brings us to our next topic which is the
deep state finally welcome The Wall
Street Journal there now casting doubt
welcome aboard guys on Muller's ongoing
witch-hunt claiming quote it's a tainted
and a seed impala kebaya s-- it looks
like the IG report is opening everyone's
eyes to what we have been showing you
for nearly a year and now nine
Republican lawmakers and I asking the
Justice Department to provide the names
of every person past and present was
work for Muller's probe this comes as
rot Rosenstein the FBI director ray or
set up this Thursday before the House
Judiciary Committee in what will be an
extremely explosive and revealing
hearing and this Wednesday disgraced FBI
agent Peter struck he's going to testify
on Capitol Hill behind closed doors open
the doors show some sunlight and finally
we have a bombshell new report from the
hill detailing how the former FBI
director Comey personally killed the
deal between the US government and
WikiLeaks Julian Assange and of course
Assange is actually the one living
person that we know for sure that would
be able to give proof regarding the
source of quote the emails listen to
what Assange told me when I interviewed
him in January last year did Russia give
you this information or anybody
associated with Russia our source is not
a state party so the answer for our
interactions is no you did not get this
information about the DNC John Podesta
Gmail's can you tell the American people
a thousand percent you did not get it
from Russia or everybody associated with
Russia we can say we have said
repeatedly over the last two months that
source is not the Russian government and
it is not a state party you mean we
could have gotten the truth from Julian
Assange
what did Comey hiding or is there
something we don't yet you know know
about after all we've been through
make the deal wasn't Russia prove it get
it from Assange let the American people
know the truth now we're going to keep
digging and digging until we peel back
every layer of this deep state